dear visitor you must have heard a lot  about our charming little country don't  believe those ugly rumors they are all  lies you won't find a better place to go  for long walks and if you reach a  village before nightfall you'll be safe  the wild animals are mostly harmless and  some folk customs date back to the cold  dawn of time visit the capital see the  museums and the parks then let the  properly aren't tour guides show you how  technology changed our life or you could  just enjoy the bustling nightlife  and this was only a glimpse of this  marvelous country this year we will open  up new regions in bako via for our  esteemed guests come back and visit us  for new adventures  you